اولادت وكاله سبوتنيك الروسيه للانباء
نقلا عن مصادر مطلعه ان القوات المسلحه
الروسيه تسلمت دفعه جديده من منظومات
استطلاع المدفعيه الصوتيه المعروف باسمي
بنسلن والتي اكدت انها اظهرت كفاءه عاليه
خلال المعارك في اوكرانيا
تكتشف بشكل فعال مواقع مدفعيه القوات
الاخرانيه وتحدد احداثياتها لتدبيرها بشكل
فوري وتستخدم منظومات
استشعار الزلزاليه وصوتيه للكشف عن مدفعيه
العدو وتحديد موقعها كما تحدد موقع نيران
العدو في غضون نحو خمس ثواني
من بيروت معنى العميد الياس حنا الخبير
والعسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك عميد
الياس حنا ماذا يعني
ادخال هذه المنظومه منظومه بنسلن المدفعيه
الروسيه الى ارض المعركه كيف من شان ذلك
ان يؤثر في الميدان
هذه المنظمات
الي صار بعدها الى ما يسمى بالكونتر باتري
يعني المدفعيه المضاده اليوم عندنا نتحدث
عن المدفعيه المقتوره والتي تستلزم وقت كي
تغير امكنتها هي غير المدفعيه المحموله
يعني هناك المدفع الفرنسي المحمول القيصر
يمكن ان يطلق ويغير مكانه في فتره بسيطه
يعني حتى خمس ثواني فاذا هذه الامور هي من
الامور التكيه خاصه على الروسيه تعتمد
مفهوم المدفعيه بشكل كامل خاصه عندما قال
يعني
المدفعيه هي الي هتقل المعركه همم في
الحرب فاذن هذه من ضمن التكتيكات الجديده
هناك اليه جديده هناك طيران جديد وهذه
عمليه اختبار مهمه للمراحل القادمه ولكن
دون شك هل ستؤثر على البعد الكبير العملات
الاستراتيجي هذا امر
تجربه مع الوقت وفي مرحله لاحقه لانه يتم
التحضير لشيء ما بعد الشتاء عن ما ذكرته
واشرت له الان العميد الياس حان تحديدا
هذه الكثافه في العمليات سواء في اخرسيون
او في دونيتك تشهد هذه الايام كشف او قصف
مكثف غير مسبوق ايضا بعد ما يجري في باخ
موت ومحاصرتها بقوات من ضمنها فاجنر ماذا
عن هذه المعطيات
عبد القادر عندما نتحدث عن خرسان هناك
نشرت على سبيل المثال نيويورك تايمز خرائط
عن التحصينات المهمه على مستويات متعدده
لنقل العسكر الموجود في خرسون الى منطقه
الشارق هذه امور مهمه وتعزيز ميليتو بول
وهي المهمه في اقليم هذه همم شيء اما في
الشارق في سباته كريمينا هناك ايضا
تعزيزات دفاعيه وراء الخطوط الاساسيه كي
لا يحصل المفاجاه كما حصل في حركه فاذن
الاستعداد هو لعمليه دفاعيه بانتظار
الهجوم الكبير المكان الوحيد الذي يحقق
فيه الجيش الروسي تقدم اساسي هو في بخمود
وهذا همم
دور الشيشان ياتي الدور العسكري الجديد
هذه هي الاساس بموت همم تشهد معارك عنيفه
منذ اسابيع طويله عميد الياس حناء ما
اهميه ان تستحوذ عليها الروسيه
اولا هي بديل للانسحاب من خلسون لانه
الروس اعتبروا انها هذه تعتبر هزيمه هي
تعويض لما حصل في خاركاب هي مهمه في
المرحله السابقه السي وليس الان قبل سقوط
الزوم قبل سقوط قبيانسك وقبل سقوط حركات
اليوم هذه مهمه تحضيره للمراحل القادمه
كما يقال هو عمليه تحسين الموقع التكتيكي
والاستراتيجي لاي مرحله قادمه لانه محمود
قد تكون الباب الى كرامه تورس اشرطه اكثر
من مره اخذنا الى المراحل القادمه ما بعد
الشتاء قبل يومين كان لافتا ما ذكره
الرئيس الاكراني عندما قال ان سته اشهر
القادمه سوف تشهد همم تغييرات مهمه هل هذا
يتقاطع مع بعض ذكرته الان
بالطبع البارحه كان هناك حمله من قائد من
وزير الدفاع قائد الجيش العملاني على
الارض ومن الرئيس الاسكي يحضرون الاجواء
الاعلاميه وكانها رساله للغرب ان الروس
يحضرون لشيء ما حتى يحضرون في احتمال لتها
هجمات مهمه من ذا فالوجيا ومن الدباس وحتى
يقال انه من بيلاروسيا وهذا الامر يتم
التركيز عليه كثيرا لانه هناك تحضيرات
مهمه وكان الرئيس ليست يقول للغرب يجب ان
تساعدونا كي نصل فعلا في مرحله لاحقه الى
التحرير ومن ثم الى العمليه الدبلوماسيه
اشكرك جزيلا الشكر على العميد الياسحنا
على الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي ضيفنا من
بيروت شكرا لك